hey everybody Sean McGinnis here after a
series of leaks Naughty Dog has finally
officially confirmed the last of us for
PlayStation 4 the game is called The
Last of Us remastered and will be
released this summer various retailers
are listing the game for sixty dollars
we've confirmed that the ps4 version of
the game will run in 1080p include
higher resolution character models
improved lighting and shadows and
upgraded textures have directors
commentary featuring creative director
of Neil druckmann as well as voice
actors Troy Baker who played Joel and
Ashley Johnson who played Ellie and
finally it will include the
single-player DLC expansion left behind
as well as the multiplayer map packs
abandoned territories and reclaimed
territories there are several pre-order
bonuses available as well such as bonus
skins for Joel and Ellie and increased
crafting healing and gun upgrades for
the single-player campaign plus if you
preorder a digital copy from the
PlayStation Store you'll also get early
access to multiplayer bonuses for all
the details check out our article on
gamespot com so what do you think is
sixty dollars too much to pay for a game
released last year where's the last of
us one of those games that's still worth
every penny let us know what you think
in the comments